doctor's report an alarming rise in
injuries related to electric scooters
amid a nationwide spike in their
popularity they are popping up in cities
from coast to coast and renters they can
use an app on their phone to rent the
devices from companies like birdlime and
skip
but as Mireya Villarreal shows us the
increase in ridership is leading to a
rise in emergency room visits the breaks
were completely gone
Lisa Beardsley says she suffered torn
ligaments and a hairline fracture in her
arm when she was forced to jump off what
she says was a malfunctioning bird
scooter about two months ago when I
landed I slid about five feet and the
bird landed on top of me from California
to Texas to Washington DC officials have
been scrambling to control the rising
use of electric scooters and now doctors
say they're seeing an uptick in injuries
I think part of it is inexperience
people are not used to riding these this
urgent care facility in Santa Monica
California has treated hundreds of
scooter injuries if I see only one a day
that's kind of the norm if I don't see
one on a day I'm really surprised
UCLA's Medical Center in Santa Monica
started counting scooter injuries in
July there were 60 that month and they
estimate 75 in August
everything from wrist and leg fractures
to major head injuries Beardsley says
her injuries from the faulty brakes
might require surgery she's planning to
file a lawsuit did you complain a bird
yes I did all I got was an apology hope
you're okay that was in and clearly or
not no bird says it does daily safety
inspections and has a fleet of what the
company calls bird watchers so the bird
watchers go around every day and they
scan every single bird determining is it
in a good safety State or not if it's
not they'll take it off the road safety
is our top priority we're obsessed about
safety but it's not just riders getting
hurt it was like I was walking down the
pier and I got hit by a motor vehicle
dancing Dave Peterson is a street
performer he says he lost months of work
and had to simplify his act at
man on a scooter hit him from behind and
left I have a broken arm here and my
right bicep was actually severed I'm
angry bird says it's updating its app so
that people can report irresponsible
riders and they tell every rider to wear
a helmet and recommend writing in bike
lanes doctors have said with a number of
riders increasing we've also seen the
number of accidents increasing what do
you tell those doctors it actually has
been proven that their safety in numbers
the more scooters that will ride in the
bike lanes the safer they are so your
solution is more bird riders more bird
riders absolutely for CBS this morning
video via del Los Angeles notice a lot
of those injuries are adults remember
when we were kids scooters were just for
kids that's changed yeah and you got to
be careful tony moran t in the studio
always puts it in perspective
next time walk I'm thinking Danica may
be single you're welcome to somebody
would be interested in contacting des
everybody needs a helmet helmet